what um are you doing with regards to
these um scholarships or grants for new
artists because
when i first heard about this 70 million
dollar purchase i thought
wow is there not like a better use of
money and i had to
think to myself okay what is the
motivation of this person okay they're a
collector great
but they obviously must care about the
arts and i just immediately thought well
if you had 70 million dollars and you
gave i don't know
700 artists a hundred thousand dollars
you could basically
and had the rights to their first
hundred works maybe that would be a
better bet
and then i look in my research that the
team at inside gave me
and they do a great job with the
research and great job to the team here
uh on today's event
they they told me that you're doing
exactly that
so tell us about your support of new
artists i find it fascinating so
by the way i find you fascinating by the
way
you seem like you're a very honest
assessor of
crypto and i thought you might be a
little bit um
more of a fanatic you seem very logical
you're a developer or what did you do
before uh so
yeah i i i'm i come i'm uh
i'm definitely a coder um i've i've been
coding since
uh 2002 uh 2003 so
yeah i don't i don't get to quote it a
lot these days but yeah yeah i am a
coder
yeah to to go back to your expression of
integrators and grants so i've like
there are two kinds of grants that
you know like i'm looking at so one is
as as metaphors the nfd fund
we are doing exactly that right like
where we are going
going after artists and and we're going
after
you know like it's especially things
that are changing the medium a little
bit
so taking nfts and seeing that you know
if there is a unique use case to it or
or our unique way someone is using into
the real world
we would immediately go support it right
like so there are a lot of these
social courses um um related to
uh art right now and those are those
artists are
moving on to the blockchain so we are we
are big on it right so
we have a team of four uh at least uh
who are
who are picking these arts all the time
so it's not just me so that's one thing
and the and the other part with the
creative
creator program itself the grants itself
what we were thinking
is we need a lot more people to educate
uh
the the new newcomers into the industry
about
you know like how do they understand
nfts and
where do they start right like it's it's
really
when we are building we are just head
down and we just talk technical all the
time right like we we skip a lot of
things
for example we will not even say crypto
boxes we'll just say
cv right and and we just assume people
understand but
the thing is it's like when we when i
use the word metaverse
it's a magical word right like people
are like maybe
the guy puts on the vr and that's how we
get started they have this romantic idea
about it but it's not true
the matter was just a url right now and
anyone can actually visit it
right and the metaverse can be 2d also
right so
i feel like the clubhouse app is it's
part of the materials
and it's a very different idea i have
and so i want to create this whole
system where you know there are creators
who get supported
and also also content creators who are
supporting these
creators to to kind of
take their message and amplify them what
type of when you give that hundred
thousand dollar grant
what are you getting out of it do you
get the right to buy their art do you
get their first 10 pieces
or is it literally a gift no it's a gift
it's a gift why would you do a gift why
would you not
have some financial upside in this
because if you got to own their first i
don't know 10 pieces
and got half of it and then you would
because you're the greatest collector
now in this space
wouldn't that validate them and then you
could put them on the market again and
get this sort of
flywheel going so i see him not
cutthroat enough
so i i i feel like you know like i i
i really like how you are speaking to
roham and how he was talking about you
know like
this new in new world and that's very
true
um the artists are get getting a lot
more import right now
and i feel like you know trying to
trying to earn goodwill is is much
better and as an
as an asset right now and and that's
that's what i'm focused on
so i i will stand in the queue right
like if someone is dropping an nft i
would i would never break the queue so
i've
i've told this a bunch of times and i
try to bid
and be part of the auction because i
feel like that's that's more of the
narrative it creates that
moment where everyone would remember it
etc so
if i if i just buy an nft and put it in
my wallet you don't even know what's
happening right like i have to come to
you and explain to you what just
happened so
it's it's the there are a lot of things
going on you know like
so it's just better to buy nfts rather
than
commissioning them except i am
commissioning a few pieces
but it will be from very different
artists who are
maybe not digital artists yet and i want
want to pull them into this industry
i'm doing a few commissions yeah that to
me is the most fascinating part about
this is
the smart contracts and what the
downstream
um economy might look like for these
nfts because
you know you saw an emergence of
uh entrepreneurship come out of airbnb
so some people were renting a room but
then other people said wait a second
maybe if i had 20 apartments or 20
locations i could make a real business
out of this
etsy ebay right on down the line line
and it feels to me like
with these new artists if they could be
commissioned for a hundred pieces
at a thousand dollars each but they got
to negotiate
half of the sale or two thirds of the
sale um
and then maybe or maybe they get you
know 50
of the sale and then on resell half that
25
next we sell half that and then a flat
fee of five percent after that
it's just so many great opportunities
aren't they yeah yeah and i i
like whatever you're saying here is is
is something that can be explored right
that's the freedom we have right now and
i think every deal is different
and and there is so much of uh activity
right
happening right now so every everyone
talking to us has a different deal
we have no standard deals right now
right so so we're giving away
like we are like uh for for each person
on on a
on a like deal by deal basis is how how
we are negotiating right now
and that's how it is because we don't
know what's going to win as a model too
right so let's see let's see maybe in
this in in a
in six months to a year i think there'll
be this emergence of a standard
of how this relationship could be yeah
and that's the amazing thing about open
standards isn't it that
everybody gets to try what their view is
i have to say like coming into this
event i was excited
uh or i was intrigued about nfts and now
after speaking to
or just get you know sitting through
this and speaking to you guys uh and
hearing all these great talks i'm like
actually
really excited about the potential here
um
wha what are your thoughts on the
grifters and
the scammers in crypto and the impact
they're having on
sort of making the space look bad
while actually there's some great stuff
emerging out of
the ico wreckage of the last three or
four years and did you participate in
those crazy icos i'm just curious how
you look at it as a really early true
believer
so um i i how do i say
yeah it is it is a it's the wild wild
west
right and and you're going to have all
kind of players it's
it's you cannot regulate away just the
bad
players it's it's very hard right and if
you if you stop someone
i'll give you an example once you
started regulating
the icos what has happened is that icos
moved out of the us
and then us only the accredited and the
funds in the u.s could participate in
these icos
while the rest of the world could right
take
take flow for example flow was not
offered to the us
and flow was off but flow was offered to
the
to the to the vc companies and a lot of
people outside
a lot of people outside the us made
money right so
it's a it's a double-edged swat right
like so you're also missing the good
opportunities not just the bad ones so
i feel like it's very important for
people to understand the change in this
phenomenon
and ha do their own research and be very
careful
because that the problem which is you
know if you're
that the world has a way to take take
the money away from a stupid person
still exists and it's very true right
and stupid people lose their money
quickly
quickly and like crypto is like walking
in a street in somalia with cash in your
pockets
so it is it is risky but i mean the last
time
the last time i went to somalia and i
was going to the cafe i didn't bring any
cash
i didn't bring any cash i just did
bitcoin for everything but yes you wanna
if you've seen the movie black hawk down
somalia is not the place you want to go
with a briefcase full of cash
i love your analogy but yes be careful